MY COLLEAGUE AND ACRE OF
"FOX NEWS @ NIGHT,"
SHANNON BREAM, TELLS US ABOUT
CALIFORNIA LAW AND THE CHALLENGE
TO IT.
>> BLUSTERING WINDS AND PELTING
RAIN DIDN'T KEEP HUNDREDS OF
DEMONSTRATORS FROM SOUNDING OFF
ON A KEY FREE-SPEECH CASE BEFORE
THE NATION'S HIGHEST COURT.
TODAY, THE JUSTICES HEARD A
DISPUTE OVER A CALIFORNIA LAW
THAT REQUIRES MOST PRO-LIFE
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO CLIENTS
ABOUT WHERE THEY CAN FIND LOW OR
NO COST ABORTIONS.
IN SEVERAL OF THE CENTERS SUED,
ARGUING THERE FREE-SPEECH RIGHTS
ARE INFRINGED BY BEING FORCED TO
SUPPORT A MESSAGE ANTITHETICAL
FOR THE CORPORATION.
JUSTICE GINSBURG ASKED THE
PLAINTIFFS LAWYER WHY THEY
SHOULDN'T EQUATE TO THE IDEA OF
INFORMED CONSENT.
"SO THAT THE PATIENT WILL KNOW
WHAT ARE THE ARRAY OF SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO HER."
BUT A NUMBER OF JUSTIN'S
QUESTIONS TO COME IF THE LAW IS
BASED ON MAKING SURE POTENTIAL
PATIENTS ARE FULLY INFORMED, WHY
IT IS FULL OF EXCEPTIONS AND
CARVE OUTS FOR NUMEROUS MEDICAL
FACILITIES AND PROVIDERS,
LEAVING NONPROFIT, PRO-LIFE
PREGNANCY CENTERS AS THE ONE
SETTLED WITH DISCLOSURE AND
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
CITING ASSISTED TICK THAT 1980 9
CITING ASSISTED TICK THAT 1980 .
CITING ASSISTED TICK THAT 1980 %
ARE PRO-LIFE FACILITIES, JUSTICE
ALITO SAID WHEN YOU PUT ALL THIS
TOGETHER, GO TO VERY SUSPICIOUS
PATTERN.
MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION CENTERED
ON THE REQUIREMENTS, THAT MANY
PRO-LIFE PREGNANCY CENTERS WOULD
BE FORCED TO USE A DISCLAIMER,
OFFICE AND MULTIPLE LANGUAGES,
AND AS THEY RUN FOR ABOUT BART'S
WEBSITES.
JUSTICES KENNEDY AND SONYA
SOTOMAYOR QUESTIONED WHETHER THE
DISCLOSURE PORTION OF THE LAW
WAS OVERLY BURDENSOME.
POST ARGUMENT, BOTH SIDES SAID
THEY ARE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
WINNING OFFER AT LEAST FIVE OF
THE JUSTICES.
CALIFORNIA MADE THE CASE THAT
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       W
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       M
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       N
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       S
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       H
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       A
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       T
THESE FAKE WOMEN'S HELPS       H
CENTERS CANNOT OPERATE WITHOUT
BEING RELIANT ON LIES AND
DECEPTION.
>> IT'S ONE THING FOR GOVERNMENT
TO BAN SPEECH, THAT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
BUT IT'S EVEN WORSE FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH AND TURN YOU INTO THEIR
MARIONETTES, THEY CAN FORCE YOU
TO SAY WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
SAY.
>> TWO OF THE JUSTICES ASKED
TODAY WHETHER THE ISSUE WAS EVEN
RIGHT TO HERE AS CALIFORNIA
NOTED, IT HAS NOT BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY ENFORCING THIS LAW.
BRET, WHATEVER THEY DECIDE, THE